Ross, we gotta start with some "Sex and the City".
Of course!
Because it's the best show ever
and I still binge it all the time
and we're all patiently waiting for the reboot to come
and save us all and distract us out of our woes.
And we know Carrie, Miranda and Charlotte are back,
but what about the rest of the cast?
I can't stop thinking about this.
Well, Willie Garson is back, who plays Stanford.
By the way, I've known Willie like my entire life.
It's hilarious.
Love him.
There's rumors that Miranda, Steve and Mr. Big
won't be returning.
Wait, what?
Yeah, will not.
That's the rumor that they won't be returning
and I'm furious.
2021! (cries)
You didn't need this today, right?
Well, I-
You take it away, Rossi,
I'm too upset to talk.
I know, well listen, we all are still
processing the Kim Cattrall news
that she's not gonna be there, right, Samantha,
but now US Weekly says the actor Chris Noth who played Big,
he's finally commented on this saying very cryptically,
quote, "Everything changes, including announcements
in the rags."
Oh!
Which means like, the magazine.
So maybe it's a fluid situation.
Girl, we need you now, all right?
I need them all to show up.
Enough of this playing coy, will they or won't they?
You're showing up Mr. Big.
You understand, Steve?
(Drew sobs)
I know, I know.
After the here we've had, we need this.
We need you to come together for us, all right, team.
Just take one for the team, we're gonna do this.
Okay.
It's design week and we've got an amazing story
about how technology is changing the way
we design our kitchens.
Apartment Therapy reports
a company called BlueStar can custom print a decal for you
for your fridge and oven to make it perfectly match
with your wallpaper, or just turn it into art itself.
You need to have, and this is an important detail,
a high-res picture so that they can scan it correctly
and properly and then you can turn anything into anything.
I loved this story.
Maybe we can decal the entire cast
of "Sex and the City" together.
(laughs) Now you're thinking.
I mean, the possibilities are endless.
Would you ever do something like this in your kitchen?
Absolutely.
Would you match your wallpaper or something offsetting?
Well I love like when wood goes over a fridge
or a fridge has a color or I love when kids pictures
are magnetized to the fridge,
which now all fridges metal doesn't magnetize anymore.
So thanks so much for that development.
(laughter)
No, it's true!
Wait, what?
It devastates me.
And then you scotch tape the art,
but then that becomes like, it pulls off.
Just let me put some magnets in kids art,
but yes, I would love to turn any appliances
into something more artistic.
We did a Drew's News version.
Oh!
(applause)
Yes.
Right, Rossi?
Yes, so is that going in your kitchen?
Well, I was thinking we could kick it here
and be like a Facebook or something.
That's cute!
Like have cool industrial
Gen-Z or office style.
All right, when you do, I wanna see it, whatever you put
in your kitchen, okay?
We'll do together, Rossi.
What's our next story?
Well finally, Drew,
we've got a lovely story about Prince Harry
and Meghan Markle.
Everybody's talking about them right now.
HuffPost reports the couple has stepped into help
The Genesis Women's Shelter in Dallas, Texas
after everything's gone so wrong in Dallas.
It was badly damaged in the storm.
Meghan and Harry, they recently quit their Royal posts,
but this proves they're planning to keep up
their public service, which is such a large part
of being a Royal.
And they actually sit down.
Are you gonna watch with Oprah
for an in-depth?
Oh yes.
Yeah.
March 7th, it's the same day, actually,
as the Queen's Commonwealth Day message from Windsor Castle.
So they're like almost counter-programming each other,
which is interesting.
I'm very impressed with everything that they're doing
and actually Meghan and Harry's inspiring story
of service actually led us to this story and we're moving
onto another pair of do-gooders or Drew-gooders
doing amazing work for their home state.
The Guess Family Barbecue in Waco, Texas
survived the storm, and now they are firing
up their pits to feed Oncor Linemen who are working
tirelessly to restore the power in their community.
And guess what?
They're here to tell us about it.
The owners of Guess Family Barbecue,
Gene Vinnykov and Reid Guess.
(applause)
Hi guys!
Hey there!
Thank you for doing this.
Oh, Gene and Reid, thank you so much
for doing what you're doing.
You survived the storm.
What was the connection for you
of what to do next by feeding the workers
who are tirelessly getting the power back on?
Yeah, Reid actually called me on Monday morning
and he actually wanted to open up a shelter
for anybody who lost power or water,
as a lot of our friends and family and colleagues.
And after talking it through a little bit
and figuring out, hey,
I don't know if we can open as a shelter,
just we weren't capable of doing that.
We got a call from Oncor
and coordinated one meal just to feed their staff.
And I called Reid and Reid said
"Absolutely, this is our time."
And we kind of made a decision that we're gonna feed
all the people that we can.
And we started on Monday afternoon,
firing up our pits and getting going
to feed people of Oncor.
Yeah, it started out as just one meal
and after we lifted our inventory
and saw what we had and what we were able to give.
It was pretty easy decision to try
to get these guys back in here.
So we ended up doing three meals a day
for three days for all of them.
So it was like 700 meals, something like that.
I mean, first of all, thank you
for what you are doing.
Ross.
Well, I just, you know, I'm so inspired because we look
at this stuff on the news and you think, what can we do?
And here you guys are doing it.
You've seen this devastation firsthand, too.
And I'm curious what your message is
for everyone in Texas watching right now.
Texas is as strong of a state as they come.
And I think this was a way of showing it.
We weren't prepared for this in no way, shape or form.
A lot of us lost food and water
and a lot of restaurants that we know
were not able to reopen the same way we were.
So we were fortunate we were able to pass it on,
but we wanna continue this.
And we are gonna continue this.
And we hope that Texas continues to do that
and it continues to help our neighbors.
Is this a seed of an idea that businesses
in their community should reach out
to other businesses and see what can come together?
For sure.
Everything that we've been able to do
for other people during this time has come
from tons of phone calls and tons of just, you know,
communication between nonprofits, between the city,
our awesome mayor, you know.
You have to communicate
and people aren't necessarily willing to ask
for help and people don't wanna always ask for help.
So it's good to call people
and check on them and make sure that, you know,
if you have something to offer when you call,
it's almost easier for them to take the help.
Like, hey, we're bringing this food, you know?
A lot of people want to help,
but don't know how, when and where.
So I think this is a really great example
of how communication can be a real game changer for people.
This is just, it's so inspiring
on so many levels and in honor
of the great work that you're doing for your community,
our friends at Tyson Foods is donating more
than $15,000 worth of protein products to help continue-
Wow!
To help continue to feed
those who are working endlessly.
In fact, the 18 Wheeler truck is on its way right now.
Right now.
(applause)
Inspired by you.
We're gonna make sure
those go to the right homes.
Thank you.
I just wanna say a huge thank you again to our friends
at Tyson who are helping us be a part of moments like this
and Reid and Gene, for everything that you are doing.
There are so many layers to this story that are inspiring,
innovative, and incredibly hopeful.
But most of all, to everyone in Texas,
we just want you to know
that our thoughts and our prayers are with you.
(upbeat music)